Bootstrap is big, and
it has to be big to accommodate its impressive array of features.
That means that the files that make up the framework are actually pretty large.
This also means that for a small project like yours,
you aren't going to ever need or even use all the functionality.
But, luckily, Bootstrap allows us to pick and
choose just the parts of the framework that we need,
making the CSS file that we include with our project significantly smaller.
To customize, we'll simply go up to the Customize button at the top menu, and
then we'll choose the parts that we need.
Let's go ahead and start by unchecking everything.
For our project, we're going to need typography, grid system and modals.
After we've checked those we'll scroll down and
when we get to the bottom of the screen we see this Compile and Download button.
I want you to follow the same steps that we just went through and
click this button.
What type of file do you download when you press Compile and Download?
Is it a CSS file, an HTML file, or a ZIP file?